talk about fair use and how can fair use
help save a filmmaker let's just throw
out a number six figures 100 000
or more in expenses on their film
and what is fair use go ahead um
well let's start off with the question
what is fair use first which i think can
succinctly be be answered with the
explanation that it's really a person's
right
to use a limited amount of copyrighted
material
without permission from the copyright
holder and
and that word limited i think is really
key and it also needs to be used for the
purpose of comment or criticism
so documentary films lend themselves to
fair use
i think in every instance you know
you're doing a historical documentary
about anything
you're going to want to show clips or
stills or something that represents what
you're talking about
um so that's really what fair use is in
a very quick nutshell
and then in terms of saving clients
money you know that's not the purpose of
fair use but it's certainly a nice
benefit
but in terms of when you're using fair
use you don't have to license them
from the copyright holder so that in and
of itself means you're going to be
saving some money
um people often come to us and say oh we
can't afford you we can't afford you but
we have a hundred thousand dollar budget
for licensing clips
and it's like well let's rethink that a
little bit it's like well
you know you come to us our fee is not
nearly that much
and you can use things that are under
your right to use materials under fair
use
although we can give you before you
leave
an article from the new york times that
showed talked about a film where we say
400 000. so it just
it is an unintended consequence
the purpose of the copyright act which
many people don't realize is to
encourage
new works so the creation of new works
is a is a is why we have copyright law
and if it helps the creation of new
works to
use a little bits of other people's
stuff
that is in furtherance of the copyright
law not
in opposition to the copyright law
so does let's say five minutes of clip
constitute copyright infringement versus
one minute
oh that's under the fair use time limit
or am i
has nothing to do with that i think
because the
the key is when a documentary is are you
using it legitimately to
illustrate some point you're already
making and do you use what's reasonably
appropriate
and sometimes that's a short bit and
then it's it's whatever it takes to
but know more than what it takes to
illustrate
what you're trying to illustrate and
then is the connection clear
so it isn't a matter of seconds
you take a photograph it's going to be
you take a film it's going to it is
going to be
a small percentage but you can't put
just a percentage or a fixed number and
say that's it
filmmakers so often have a notion that
they
you know 30 seconds or less is fine or
with a song six seconds or less is fine
and they come up with these
with these rules which are totally
inaccurate um however courts do look at
how much they use that is certainly one
of the factors that courts look at is
how much of the underlying work do they
use
and that i think goes part and parcel
with another factor that's extremely
important with fair use is
will it how will it affect the market so
if you're going to
displace that market someone's going to
watch your movie instead of the movie
which you took a clip from
that's going to weigh heavily that it's
not fair use if it's not affecting that
market
and in so many cases with documentary
it's actually helping the market you do
a
film on the history of um of asian asian
american movies or something and you
show all these clips from asian american
movies more people are going to want to
go and see those movies
so that weighs in favor of the fair use
argument but there's not a hard and fast
rule which again is one of these notions
that people
think there are let's take another
position
let's say i'm a filmmaker who's had
my content taken and put in someone's
film
and this other filmmaker is claiming
well it's fair use
who is this jury that determines
how appropriate that clip was let's
suppose it was
something that i felt hey that was my
work and it's more than
appropriate or whatever the terminology
you had used earlier that
to determine or to to make a point about
something right
what what would i do in that case let's
suppose my work's been taken
theoretically the first thing you do is
really understand what is and
isn't fair use
the book talks about three different
ways
of answering that question the statutory
way
the safe harbor way which i just
outlined to you
and then there's a best practices
booklet that
also is relevant these are different
ways
and you want to really be sure that
no matter how you come at the question
you land up with the answer
hey this is not fair use
then you go get a
good litigator or you might just
call first and see if you can work it
out with a filmmaker because so many
many
filmmakers are willing to pay a
reasonable license
and you can tell pretty quickly if they
consulted with a lawyer if they really
had good guidance or if they used it
hoping you wouldn't know and when you
called they say up it's fair use
so you know it's a
i mean a good example is that it's you
know music is
is i think an easy way to look at that
music if someone's using music as score
for a creative purpose regardless of how
short it is even if it's three seconds
well always opine that's not fair use
because you're simply using it for the
creative
value of it and because you like that
song if you're using
music because you're commenting on and
you're talking about a certain song by
elvis presley that he's saying and you
show a little bit of that
that's fair use but once you start using
that song and score underneath the next
um talking head who's in your
documentary that's no longer fair use
because you're using it just for the
creative purpose
so you as as a copyright holder who's
had your stuff
infringed upon or used under fair use
would want to look at that are they
using it for the creative value of it or
are they using it because they're really
commenting on my work
you